we now come to questions to the Prime
Minister Sir Sir Bill wiggin
question number one well
Deputy Prime Minister
Madam W speaker I've been asked to reply
on behalf of my right honorable friend
the Prime Minister who is attending the
funeral of baroness Betty boothroid I'm
sure the whole house would want to join
me in paying tribute to baroness
boothroid the first female speaker of
the house and our thoughts and prayers
are with her family
I'm sure the whole house
duck join in sending our thoughts and
prayers about baroness boothroid whom we
all held in very high esteem
so Bill Wigan thank you madam Deputy
speaker phosphates leaching into the
river why could be stopped by proven
phosphate stripping technology attached
to anaerobic digesters but herefordshire
council's bypass hating green and
independent group support or engage
despite a moratorium on house building
what can he do to save our River and
remove the capsule from such a vital
strategic and environmental
responsibility
after the Prime Minister thank you madam
Deputy speaker the river y obviously
it's of huge importance to Nature we're
taking action to tackle pollution and
raise farming standards he'll know about
the environment agency's uh Farm
inspection capacity and catchment
sensitive farming advice program and I
defer to his technical knowledge in this
area I'm sure he'll want to make
submissions to the local Authority
Deputy leader on the opposition Angela
Rainer
thank you madam Deputy speaker and
welcome back into the chair and can I
share the Deputy Prime Minister's word
on our baroness and our thoughts with
her family today and I'm sure the whole
house will join me also in paying
tribute to Paul O'Grady after his sad
death with Lance today he was a National
Treasure and a true Northern Star and he
will be greatly missed
Madame devices speaker this week the
government announced their so-called
anti-social Behavior policy it's only
taken 13 years and look I'll give him
some credit the Deputy Prime Minister
knows firsthand the misery cause by
Thugs and their intimidating Behavior
lurking with Menace exploding in fits of
Rage creating a culture of fear and
maybe even I don't know throwing things
so can I ask him
under his new anti-social Behavior does
he think More Bullies will be brought to
Justice
[Applause]
speaker I can reassure the house I've
never called anyone scum
foreign
[Applause]
but if the right honorable lady is
serious about standing up for
communities and people who suffer at the
scourge of anti-social Behavior should
back our plan to deal more swiftly with
these issues to make sure that we ban
drugs beyond the conventional ones give
police the powers they need and if they
really if they really want to protect
the public they'll back our plans for
parole reform to make sure the murderers
the terrorists the child killers are not
allowed out free to to threaten other
people and reintroduce the ministerial
veto that that side took away
Madam Deputy speaker I'd like to see the
ministerial cold being introduced under
there too on that side of the house
because it's not just his department
where anti-social behavior is running
out of control it's happening across the
country police officers disappearing
from our streets replaced by criminals
plague in our towns and leaving people
feeling unsafe the true benefits that
the conservatives are missing in action
in the fight against Crime so can he
tell his constituents and the public why
after 13 years of his party in
government there are now 6 000 fewer
neighborhood police officers on Britain
streets
Madam W speaker she really does have a
brass neck because they voted against
our funding of Police recruitment and
the 20 000 extra police officers but
what I will tell her in the whole house
is crime is lower than it was under the
last Labor government
violent crime is halved
reoffending is seven percentage points
lower and if she really wants to stand
up for the public and the victims of
crime they should back our bill to
protect victims and protect the most
vulnerable from serious kill at serious
Killers rapists and terrorists
radar bottom Deputy speaker No One
Believes that there's more police on the
street so no one feels safer
neighborhood policing has gone down the
not up let's talk about crime he knows
as well as I do that neighborhood police
can help prevent anti-social behavior
and knife crime but trusted local police
are also crucial to protecting women
women feel unsafe on Britain streets
always looking over our shoulder as we
hurry to our front door so can he tell
me under his watch as Justice secretary
what is the charge rate for rape
can I address all those elements of that
and first of all say that the issue of
rape and serious sexual violence against
women is one of our top priorities
she asked she asked what we're doing
about it since 2019 police referrals of
cases are doubled CPS charges have
doubled she asked she asked on my watch
what has happened the volume of
convictions in rape cases increased by
two-thirds and if she really wants to
protect vulnerable women whether it's
rapists or from rapists or other serious
crimes they will back our parole reforms
which will mean ministers able to
prevent uh them being released onto the
public and cause more threats
[Applause]
he says that rape conviction has gone up
what he really means is that 300 women
will be raped a day while he boasts
about an increase of 0.5
he has an answered my question Madam
Deputy speaker because he's too ashamed
of the answer
[Applause]
point six percent of rapist base being
charged for their crime
1.6 let that sink in a woman goes
through the worst experience of her life
she summons up the courage to relive
that a horrendous experience to tell the
police in detail about her assault but
she only has a 1.6 chance of action
being taken over 98 of rapists will
never see the inside of a courtroom let
alone a prison and the rest of those
Brave women Madam Deputy speaker they
keep looking over their shoulders and
hope the perpetrator doesn't choose
tonight to take their revenge for
reporting the incident to the police
in the last 13 years of the Tory
government more than half a million
cases of rape have been recorded by the
police but their charge rate for those
attacks have collapsed he has served
under five Tory Prime Ministers and had
three years as Justice Minister and on
his watch rapists are left to roam the
streets so will he apologize to those
victims who will never get Justice
because of his failures
first of all say to the right honorable
lady the conviction rate measured by the
CPS the leader of the labor party used
to be in charge of CPS he might want to
point this out well actually the the
conviction rate has gone up it is now at
69 we are doing much more to support the
victims of rape when they come forward
well they're talking a good game in fact
we have quadrupled funding for victims
since 2010 and if she looks at the
latest data the time it's taken from
charge to completion of a rape case has
come down by come come down by 10 weeks
or 70 in the last three months alone she
should get her facts straight
particularly when talking about such a
sensitive issue
[Applause]
Madame Deputy speak he won't apologize
for the government failures on charge
rates and 69 of 1.6 they usually that's
really something to boast about
let me ask him about an issue which is
directly his responsibility on his watch
rape survivors are waiting on average
more than three years for their cases to
come to court The Honorable member
talked about 10 week 10 week reduction
three years Deputy Deputy leader three
years so ten weeks is not anything to
boast about those three years from the
day of the assault to the final day of
court is it any wonder that from April
till September last year 175 trials for
rape and other serious sexual offenses
have had to be dropped because the
victim could no longer cope with a delay
so let me ask him when will he apologize
to all those women denied Justice
because of his failure to keep the
thought the court backlog
but she ignores the impact on the
court-back club of the pandemic or
indeed the CBA strike but let me tell
her what we're doing let me tell what
we're doing we've quadrupled funding for
victims since 2010 quadrupled the
funding provided by the last Labor
government we launched the 24 7 support
line so that when those victims of that
appalling crime come forward they get
the support they need we've increased
the number of independent sexual
violence advisors to over a thousand and
we're making sure that women uh that
suffer this appalling crime can give
pre-recorded evidence in court we're
doing everything that we can and as I
said uh the the rates are coming down
and we will keep uh uh taking action
this area is she really if the labor
party were really serious about this
they wouldn't have voted against longer
sentences for Dangerous violent and
sexual offenders in the police crime
sentencing a court set and she will get
behind our victims and prisoner bill
today yeah
[Applause]
Madam Deputy speaker not a word of
apology no sense of responsibility and
not even a shred of Shame the reality is
while people in Britain feel more and
more unsafe he seems to spend all of his
time trying to save his own job and none
of his time on his actual job and it's
not just me that thinks so the Prime
Minister clearly doesn't trust him to
deal with anti-social Behavior because
he's given that job to the leveling up
secretary the way things are going and
reports are to be believed this might be
your last pmqs so let's look at the
highlights a criminal justice on its
knees the largest Court backlog on
record rape victims waiting for justice
and through it all he managed to wrap up
24 far more complaints from his own
civil servants so can he say today
Willie walk before he's pushed
Deputy speaker one thing never changes
she always comes with a usual Bluster
and political opportunism
let me let me tell let me tell the right
honorable lady what we've been doing
what I've been doing this week we've
delivered new legislation to support the
victims of crime including rape and to
protect the public we've delivered a
plan to Stamp Out anti-social behavior
and we've supported families with their
energy bills what's she done what the
labor front bench done they tried to
block our small boat spill and that's
the difference between them and us we
deliver for Britain she likes to play
her political aims
[Music]
Deputy speaker and it is wonderful to
see you in your place and
friend will be aware at the Thames
Freeport was recently given the final go
ahead to become fully operational
creating thousands of jobs and
attracting millions in inward investment
will my right honorable foreign friend
join me in congratulating the team
behind the bid and encourage businesses
and investors from across the southeast
indeed across the world to take a closer
look at the Fantastic opportunities that
exist in thurrock and would he work with
local education providers to ensure my
constituents have the skills needed to
take up these fantastic opportunities
my honorable friend I certainly do
support and pay tribute to all of those
who have made the new Thames Freeport uh
possible with its potential to deliver
over 12 000 new jobs I look forward to
seeing the local community and The Wider
communities benefit from the tax
benefits the custom zones and we'll see
how these plans progress and again I
think it's good news to see the
communities in Basildon and thurrock
taking full advantage of the brexit
opportunities
the deputy leader of the SNP Murray
black
thank you madam Deputy speaker and I
also wish to say in my warm regards to
the family of Paul O'Grady the legendary
drag queen for always done for my
community I also want to congratulate
Hamza Yusuf as he becomes
[Applause]
as the
first
and Muslim to hold such an office I'm
sure the whole house will send his one
regards now in recent days video footage
has emerged of the former Chancellor and
the former chair of the 1922 committee
offering their services
for sixty thousand pounds on top of
their MP salary the former Health
secretary offered his wisdom for ten
thousand pounds a day going once can I
ask the Deputy Prime Minister when he
has inevitably booted out of office what
will his going rate mean
[Applause]
can I can I welcome her to uh the the
chamber uh the system of the system of
declarations is there to ensure
transparency and accountability and of
course the conservatives backed
tightening up those rules uh to make
sure that there couldn't be any lobbying
uh but can I also join with uh except to
take her up on her uh tribute to the
first uh the new first minister of
Scotland the Prime Minister spoke to him
last night uh we welcome him to his
place and of course the government wants
to work constructively with him in the
best interest of the people of Scotland
during a cost of living crisis as his
colleagues eye up battles of cash from
fake companies it's the people across
these aisles that have been led by
donkeys
now the former house secretary also said
that he would impact his wisdom for 1500
pounds an hour
most nurses earn little above 15 pounds
an hour who does the Deputy Prime
Minister thinks best value for money and
for the public
all right
I'm delighted that the majority of their
health unions have accepted uh the pay
settlement we we think that that's
absolutely uh we think that's absolutely
right and she she raises the issue uh
and of course we've uh We've uh worked
with on a cross-party basis to curb the
limits on second earnings I I noticed
the benches on this side are curiously
quiet
is that because there's ten Shadow
cabinet members on their benches who are
taking earnings in particular the shadow
foreign safety looks like he he
certainly doesn't want to be under the
Limelight
he's got earned second earnings from 40
different sources I I don't think uh
they can talk about it and uh as far as
the honorable lady is concerned we've
done everything we can to make sure
there's transparency in accountability
Jack Brewton
it's it's very good to see you back in
this place Stoke on Trent has been
announced as one of the leveling up
Partnerships and this is on top of the
investment we've already received
through programs like the level of your
fund and this has been delivered thanks
to conservatives working together in
government and on the city council led
by the formidable councilor Abby Brown
so would my rightmore friend agree with
me if people want to continue to see the
leveling up of opportunities in
Stoke-on-Trent they should vote
conservative in a local elections in May
[Music]
under labor it's now the conservatives
in no small part thanks to my honorable
friend who have been leveling up in
Stoke-on-Trent 11 million pounds from
the shared Prosperity fund 12 million
pounds on the leveling up fund 4 million
pounds from the regional growth fund and
that's supporting over 500 jobs and 28
million pounds of private investment
that's the difference for the people of
stoke under a conservative government
[Applause]
so Jeffrey Donald
Madam Deputy speaker yesterday the
Secretary of State told us that the
security service MI5 have increased the
terrorism Threat Level in Northern
Ireland to severe
responsibility for dealing with
terrorism and National Security rests
with the government of the United
Kingdom including in Northern Ireland
will the Deputy Prime Minister assure me
and the people of Northern Ireland that
the government will provide the Police
Service of Northland and the security
service with the resources that they
need to counter the serious terrorist
threat Deputy Prime Minister I think uh
The Honorable gentleman is absolutely
right of course the threat level is kept
under constant review we take into
account a range of factors he'll be very
familiar with those it's disappointing
that Threat Level has gone up but I
think it is worth also saying that it
has been insignificant decline in terms
of the number of uh Northern Ireland
related terrorist attacks and attempted
attacks since the peak of the violence
in 2009 2010 nonetheless of course we'll
make sure all the resources available
for the psni and the public are reminded
to remain Vigilant and Report any
suspicious behavioral activity
[Applause]
thank you madam Deputy speaker in my
recent local survey as to whether Lee
should break away from Wigan Council
yeah I am very pleased to say that so
far the survey shows 90 in favor
with only three percent opposed
please I mean before you call for a
second referendum let me finish the
question yeah
agree
our campaign for our Town's Independence
but this is the year to get lexit done
my honorable friend campaigns uh with
typical Gusto
um I think he knows that changing the
boundaries that local Authority level uh
is subject to an independent process but
I will ensure he gets the meeting with
the minister for local government so he
can further discuss the aspirations for
late yeah
cat Smith
despite Royal Mail posting record
profits management address
what conversations government is
happening with Royal Mail and what it's
doing to protect the universal Postal
Service
do prime minister it's an incredibly
difficult time can I thank her for a
question obviously the pandemic has had
a particular uh impact but we're working
very closely to make sure we can
continue the service and I'll make sure
she gets a meeting with the relevant
minister to discuss their concerns
further
Mark Eastwood
thank you madam Deputy speaker on behalf
of the people of g-spruit I would also
like to pay tribute to dewsbury's
greatest daughter Betty Boop Road she
was solely missed this week I visited
Raven Hall School in dewsbury and
hollybank school in mirfield both do
amazing work teaching children with
special educational needs and
disabilities however there is disparity
in sand standards in mainstream schools
within my constituency would my right
notable friend join me in thanking the
teachers and staff at Ravens Hall and
Holly bank for everything they do and
could he also outline how we can ensure
all our children are given the best
chance in life regardless of which
school they go to
Prime Minister can I thank my honorable
friend and pay tribute to the teachers
and the staff at both schools Ravens
Hall and Holly bank for the amazing work
they do it's a very difficult and
challenging job an incredibly important
for the life chances of those children
of affected he'll know that in March we
published the send an alternative
provision Improvement plan with new
national standards and that's backed up
by an increased specialist provision
locally with 2.6 billion pounds going
into it and that includes opening 33 new
special schools with a further 49 in the
pipeline
I hope he later gets a chance to watch
the BBC dramatization uh the brink smart
robbery which was held in the 1980s
where the police team assigned to the
recovery of the school only got back
half of the gold that was stolen that's
some appeal isn't insignificance
compared with the measly one percent
from the 1 billion pounds of business
grants that they was lost to the fraud
issued by the Prime Minister under his
watch when he was Chancellor the
fingerprints show that this massive
fraud Now lies at 10 Downing Street to
quote your former fraud Minister Lord
Bilton when will this government when
will this government get its act
together and step up the recovery
efforts on behalf of the taxpayer Deputy
Prime Minister well the the instance of
fraud had become much more complex with
the online instance but he will have
noted the massive increase in funding
for tackling fraud in the recent budget
and we're confident that will give us
the resources we need to tackle uh this
uh often invisible but very damaged in
crime
Sir Robert deal
ER
[Applause]
[Music]
the Deputy Prime Minister will know that
stroke is the greatest cause of adult
disability in this country and costs our
economies on 26 billion pounds never
mind destroying lives last year I met Dr
John Stevens who was unable even to sit
up unaided after a stroke but because of
emergency thrombectomy procedure is now
back at work as a GP in the NHS sadly
only 30 percent of eligible patients
actually get thrombectomies well the
prime adaptive prime minister agree that
we need greatly to increase the roll out
of thrombectomy procedures and really
perhaps in the run-up to world
trombectomy day next month join me in
visiting a thrombectomy Center sit
firsthand the difference it can make to
lives and to getting people back into
meaningful and productive work and
enjoyment prime minister can I thank my
honorable friend he's been a dedicated
Champion for stroke survivors I know
from my own constituency how
debilitating that can be and the impact
it has on The Wider families NHS England
are committed to increasing the delivery
of mechanical thrombectomy including the
expansion of local services and local
capital investment and I'm sure we can
arrange for a health minister to join
him on a visit as he request
thank you very much Madam Deputy speaker
in a shocking article in Surrey live
last year it's reported that staff had a
GP practice in Walton were left in tears
and crumbling under pressure due to the
increased workload caused by staff
shortages is it any wonder when there
are 850 fewer GPS across the country
since 2019. so what does the Deputy
Prime Minister say to those patients
left in pain and staff left in tears
including in his own constituency due to
this government's failed promise to
recruit more GPS
what can I say to her any abuse against
any GP in any practice across the
country is absolutely wrong we have to
have zero tolerance of it what I would
just say to us we've seen a large
increase in GP appointments over 29
million carried out since the start of
the Year we're improving access to
general practice with more support staff
also the technology so more
state-of-the-art telephone systems the
number of GPS and training is at record
levels and were invest 1.5 billion to
create 50 million more appointments a
year by 2024. if we go a bit faster
we'll get everybody in Scott Benton
foreign
since 2019 this government has provided
well over 300 million pounds in extra
funding for projects in Blackpool
however there is always room for more
the Bond Street and weather areas and my
constituency are among the most deprived
in the country and have been long
forgotten by the labor-led council the
government has already provided 600 000
pounds in funding for feasibility
project with a view to delivering a 30
million pounds regeneration package for
these areas will the government look
closely at the business case to see how
this transformational project can be
delivered to those communities
prime minister answers that can everyone
else with a prepared question just cut
it in half just do the question Deputy
Prime Minister thank you MW speaker
there is no one more tenacious in
campaigning for Blackpool than the
honorable gentleman I've seen it
firsthand when I visited with him I'm
pleased that we delivered with the
leveling up secretary the 40 million
pounds of funding to relocate the
magistrates court and to allow
um the county court complex to move and
I know that the leveling up secretary
will want to work with him on the
Regeneration aspirations for the future
Wendy Chamberlain thank you madam Deputy
speaker a little girl in my constituency
only nine years old developed a
bacterial infection just before
Christmas but thereafter very
distressing symptoms occurred OCD she
has intrusive thoughts she hasn't washed
dressed or properly eaten since
Christmas we believe this to be pans
Panda and although Health has evolved
and I am seeking support for her part of
the lottery and the antipsychotic
medication that is often given in this
condition despite the fact that
broad-based antibiotics have been proven
to work is because the UK no part of the
UK has implemented World Health
Organization icd-11 will the government
commit to looking at this so that other
children across the UK don't need to
suffer in such a way
for raising what seems like a very an
awful case and my heart goes out to the
family involved if she'd like to write
with me about it I'll make sure she gets
a full answer and a meeting with the
minister if that's required Caroline
Nooks
[Music]
Georgia Harrison is an incredibly Brave
young woman who only got Justice when
she was a victim of revenge porn because
she could prove that the perpetrator
intended to cause her distress most
victims can't and perpetrators are using
platforms to use revenge porn for
financial gain that's not covered in the
legislation will my right honorable
friend commit to looking at the case
studies Georgia has compiled and
reviewing this legislative legislation
to strengthen it and make it more
effective
Deputy Prime Minister can I thank the uh
honorable lady honorable friend all
right honorable friend for all that
she's done in this area I know that
there have been considerable number of
changes the Online safety Bill not least
because of her forensic attention to
detail they will include the creation of
a new base offense of sharing intimate
images without consent that don't
require uh proof of an intention to
cause distress and of course the
government also supports the revenge
porn helpline which offers free and
confidential advice if there are any
further changes that she thinks need to
be made very happy to look him with her
it's Brian
Madame Deputy speaker I don't know
whether the Deputy Prime Minister ever
met Lilly Savage
um or has ever spent a night out at the
Royal Vauxhall Tavern but Lily was I can
take him sometime if he wants to go
um the um but the I think that was a yes
actually yeah but the um but Lily was
performing at the height of the AIDS
crisis in 1987.
um when police officers raided the pub
arrested her amongst others
um they were wearing rubber gloves
because supposedly they're protecting
themselves from Contracting HIV from
touching gay men Lily amazingly said at
the time
um oh lad you've come to do the washing
up that's great
um her Alter Ego Paul O'Grady campaigned
acerbically and hilariously for elderly
people for care workers against
oppression of every kind isn't it time
we in this country celebrated our
naughty hilarious drag queens and comics
of every kind to inspire us to be a
better and more generous Nation
okay thank you everyone I totally agree
with him and Paul Grayson was uh
incredible comic but he also
but but
fully gravy but Lily but in terms of
Lily stage also I think some of that
comedy broke glass ceilings and broke uh
boundaries in a way that certainly
politicians would struggle to do so I
agree with that I also think it shows
how we need uh greater more rambunctious
free speech and we need to avoid the
wokery and the limitations on Comedy
which I'm afraid both of them would have
had no time for it
Madam Deputy speaker I'd like to
associate myself with the words of the
honorable gentleman from Miranda Paul
O'Grady was a great Champion for Animal
Welfare as well Madam Deputy speaker
Chuck the biggest cause of death for
children in this country under the age
of 14 is cancer as she knows I've been
calling for a Childhood Cancer mission
to radically change how we detect how we
treat and how we care for children with
cancer everything from genome science
for detection right the way through to
seven day a week play facilities and
children's Ward the health secretary has
been brilliant he's met with me and has
been really positive on this but will be
Deputy Prime Minister
restates the government's support for a
Childhood Cancer Mission yeah Deputy
Prime Minister can I thank my honorable
friend I certainly will and the
suffering that any child must go through
when they get a condition like cancer at
such an early age difficult to believe
and the pressure on the family is uh
incredible so I thank her for her work
the dhsc will publish a major condition
strategy to look at improving outcomes
and experience for all kinds of patients
but including a particular uh children I
can't preempt that but I know it will
draw on previous work including
submissions from the various Childhood
Cancer Charities and again I pay tribute
to the work that they do
hair from the Bluebell wood Children's
Hospital who were forced to temporarily
close last year due to Staffing
pressures they have ongoing concerns
about Rising bills will the Deputy Prime
Minister reassure Daniel's family that
he will receive the palliative care he
requires as and when he needs it
can I thank her for raising that very
important case that she does I don't
know all the facts of it but if she
writes to me I'm very happy to look at
it we will make sure and the resourcing
but also the care is there and if again
as I said if she writes to me I'm I'm
sure we can arrange for a meeting with
the relevant Minister Wendy Morton
Deputy speaker the inclusion of the West
Midlands as a hot spot Trailblazer
police force area in the social
antisocial Behavior action plan is
really good news could my right
honorable friend outline though how
communities such as those in my
constituency on the periphery of the
West Midlands will see and feel the
positive difference that this will bring
and that we won't simply see a
redirecting of our valuable resources by
the labor police and crime commissioner
into other parts of the West Midlands
prime minister can I thank my right on
my French you raise really important
point the and social behavior action
plan will help us crack down and make
sure on our social behavior and make
sure that those responsible conduct and
undergo repairs within 48 Hours things
like uh cleaning up litter and graffiti
in terms of the West Midlands enhanced
Hot Spot I'm delighted they'll be
getting that additional funding uh it is
she's right for the pcc's to the to
determine the precise allocation of
funding but I'm sure she'll make her
representation in the usual powerful way
merry Clinton
speaker announcing her retirement no
thanks I'd born Sarah Hunter MBA played
her final game of rugby at the opening
women's Six Nations match at Kingston
Park last Saturday Sarah is the most
capped International Rugby player in the
world a true professional great
Ambassador for her Sport and an
inspiration to so many Willow Deputy
Prime Minister join with me the Hall of
North townside and this house in
thanking Sarah for all she has achieved
for the country and her beloved Fort of
rugby
can I can I can I Thank The Honorable
lady she's absolutely right I pay
tribute to the trailblazing record of
Sarah I had the opportunity a few years
ago to watch the England female rugby
team I was blown away and we look
forward to her and them going on to
bigger and better things
Deputy speaker
Will the governments require that the
East-West rail company publish a full
business case before the allocation of
any more taxpayers money to the project
here
Deputy Prime Minister thank you it's a
hugely important project with all sorts
of opportunities jobs education and a
projected increase in economic output by
over 100 billion by 2050 he's right that
it needs all the transparency uh and
scrutiny I know that the first stage of
the project is already in construction
on time and under budget I'm told that
the subsequent stages will go through
full scrutiny as part of the planning
process in a transparent way David
Linder
hey Minister has previously been on
camera seeing that he didn't have any
working class friends and when he's not
taking his luxury helicopter rides and
splashing about his private pool we'll
make the Deputy Prime Minister recommend
it might befriend somebody from the
working class
I'm not sure I got the full extent of
the question but the reality is
um we're doing and you can see that with
the energy price guarantee uh the free
um uh child care and the national living
wage that we are supporting everyone in
this country particularly those on the
lowest paid jobs
question Alicia Kearns
okay this week rutlander Andrew Osborne
solo sailed 3 000 miles taking 78 days
across the Atlantic Ocean he raised 142
000 pounds for cardiac risk in a young
after his daughter Amy died in her sleep
a 25 being discovered by her sister the
next morning one in 12 children die
every week on diagnosed heart conditions
so can my right humble friend please
reassure me what we are doing to
increase the diagnosis of undiagnosed
heart conditions in children and young
people every prime minister can I thank
a honorable friend for raising this and
uh our heartfelt condolences go to the
family of Amy but likewise our
congratulations go to Andrew on
incredible feat the fact that 12 young
people die every week from an
undiagnosed heart condition is something
we all want to see an end to there's
more resource going in there's more
research going in and I'll arrange for a
meeting between her and the relevant
minister